well how about if you go after your
child's College Savings Program the
Nevada state treasurer's office is
launching a scholarship giveaway in
honor of national kindergarten day for
the next few weeks parents who register
a Nevada college Kickstart account for
their kindergartner enrolled in public
school will automatically be entered
into the giveaway so four lucky students
will be randomly selected to receive
529 dollars to start the program towards
a 529 College savings account a 529 is a
great way to save for college for your
for your child the giveaway is now
through May 5th and we'll have
information on how to register and how
to get started posted on our website at
eightnewsnow.com